[Música]
a 3 aumentó el número de muertos en
medio de las protestas en el sur de Perú
por otro lado y en una carta escrita con
su puño y letra al destituido presidente
Pedro Castillo calificó su detención
como un secuestro y se refirió a su
sucesora Dina boluarte como una
Usurpadora
concluyó en Venezuela el primer siglo de
negociaciones entre la guerrilla del
ejército de liberación nacional y el
gobierno de Colombia el país anfitrión
calificó los resultados como positivos y
ahora la próxima fase de los diálogos
será en México
termina oficialmente el proceso
electoral en Brasil Luis Ignacio Lula da
Silva recibió el certificado que lo
acredita como el legítimo ganador de las
elecciones presidenciales del pasado mes
de octubre y podrá tomar posesión el
primero de enero de 2023 como el nuevo
presidente del país Tenemos reporte
Hola Bienvenidos a una nueva emisión de
noticias en France 24 lo saluda a Andrés
Meza Muñoz empezamos en Perú a tres
aumentó el número de muertos por las
protestas que se desataron tras la
destitución de la obra ex presidente
Pedro Castillo la situación llevó a la
presidenta Dina boluarte a declarar el
estado de emergencia en el sur del país
y también a anunciar elecciones Para
abril de 2024 que es una de las demandas
de los manifestantes este lunes la
fiscalía también presentó ante el
congreso una denuncia constitucional
contra Castillo por los presuntos
delitos de rebelión y conspiración horas
más tarde el expresidente publicó una
carta escrita con su puño y letra en la
que calificó su detención como un
secuestro y arremetió contra boluarte
escuchemos
les habló para reiterar que soy
incondicionalmente fiel al mandato
popular y constitucional que ostento
como presidente y no renunciaré ni
abandonaré mis altas y sagradas
funciones el pueblo no debe caer en su
juego sucio de nuevas elecciones basta
de abusos asamblea Constituyente ahora
Libertad inmediata para analizar la
situación en Perú saludamos en Lima a
Omar Cairo él es analista político
abogado de la Universidad de Lima y
magíster en derecho constitucional de la
pontificia Universidad Católica de Perú
señor Cairo bienvenido France 24 frente
al tema de las elecciones esperaría que
fueran incluso mucho antes de la fecha
anunciada por la presidenta boluarte qué
tan pertinentes son estos plazos
es muy complicado que sea antes porque
se requiere organizar el proceso
electoral y la la idea de que fuera en
abril de 2023 como es como lo establece
un proyecto que está en la comisión de
constitución del Congreso es es muy
improbable lo más viable es que se han
se realicen elecciones Y es que se
aprueba el proyecto que va a presentar
la presidenta es que sea el 2024 ahora
cuál puede ser el destino de boluarte
durante estos 15 meses antes de las
elecciones
bueno todo depende de cómo se
desarrollen los acontecimientos y Y eso
tuvo un mal inicio el El golpe de estado
El Siete de diciembre fue indiscutible
en el momento en que Castillo da el
mensaje disolviendo el congreso
disponiendo la reorganización del
ministerio público del poder judicial
perdió el cargo y se convirtió un
presidente de facto Sin embargo el
congreso para
recuperar protagonismo organizó un
ritual en el cual lo declaró vacante del
cargo a quien ya no era presidente esto
en realidad fue algo que no pasó de los
pintoresco Pero lo que sí fue complicado
fue que el día de ayer el congreso en en
un solo día
declaró que el presidente castillo de
podía ser progresado judicialmente que
esto es un proceso procedimiento que se
llama ante juicio que se activa con una
denuncia constitucional eso no se puede
hacer en un solo día en el artículo 89
del reglamento del Congreso dice que hay
una serie de actos que se deben cumplir
en por lo menos dos semanas y tan cierto
es eso que hoy día la fiscal de la
nación ha presentado la denuncia
constitucional a pesar de que el
congreso ha aprobado esta resolución que
habilita el procesamiento del del
expresidente Castillo la fiscal
conociendo que esto es
anticonstitucional ha presentado el
pedido recién entonces estas situaciones
Estas ideas y venidas este este afán de
protagonizar desde sacar provecho en la
para la elección que pueda sobrevenir
puede generar muchas complicaciones lo
mejor sería que que los políticos
advirtiendo el momento de emergencia que
vive el Perú depongan estas aspiraciones
y caminen hacia una transición
sosegada y y exenta devoluciones ahora
señor Jairo que se espera que pase con
la denuncia constitucional contra
Castillo va a prosperar
es muy probable que sí pero eso va a
tomar este una o dos semanas y después
de eso lo más probable es que se le
acuse por conspiración para rebelión
porque la rebelión es un es un acto que
requiere un alzamiento en armas y sin
embargo lo que se sospecha es que ha
habido no un alcemento en armas porque
esto fue
superado en menos de una hora y no se
utilizó no se utilizó armas pero el pero
el presidente Castillo supremo las
fuerzas armadas por lo tanto se sospecha
que hubo algún concierto con uno o más
personajes civiles o militares eso es
esclares era Y sí lo hubo se le se le
podrá condenar por rebelión insinúa nada
de eso se le se le absolverá
era Omar kairo analista político Gracias
por acompañarnos aquí en France 24 para
analizar la situación
y terminó en Venezuela el primer ciclo
de negociaciones de paz entre el
gobierno colombiano y el ejército de
liberación nacional a través de un
comunicado el gobierno del país
anfitrión calificó la primera etapa como
exitosa en la semana inicial de esta
fase las partes acordaron invitar a
Estados Unidos y cuatro países europeos
como acompañantes del proceso de
negociación y a Chile Brasil y México en
calidad de garantes un rol que juegan
desde el comienzo Venezuela Cuba y
Noruega los equipos en Caracas
anunciaron que trasladarán la próxima
fase de su negociación a México esto
Dijo el gobierno venezolano sobre los
diálogos
para nuestro país su pueblo y su
gobierno ha constituido un hecho de
trascendental importancia haber podido
servir como sede inicial de este ciclo
de trabajo el cual termina con
resultados altamente positivos
contribuyendo con el desarrollo de los
diálogos por la paz que impulsa el
gobierno del presidente Gustavo Petro
vamos a Brasil Luis Ignacio Lula da
Silva fue certificado oficialmente como
el ganador de las elecciones del pasado
mes de octubre y ahora podrá tomar
posesión como presidente el próximo
primero de enero de 2023 en un emotivo
discurso el mandatario electo dijo que
con su Victoria al pueblo brasileño
reconquistó el derecho de vivir en
democracia los detalles de esta noticia
con nuestra corresponsal en Río de
Janeiro Valeria saconi
declarados hoy por el Tribunal Superior
electoral idóneos para la investidura
que se celebrará el 1 de enero en
Brasilia ha sido un acto protocolario en
Brasilia en el que hemos visto a un Lula
visiblemente emocionado que incluso ha
llorado recordando su prisión se ha
alegrado de que el pueblo brasileño haya
escogido la democracia y ha recordado
los momentos más difíciles del último
año con los ataques por parte del
Derrotado presidente bolsonaro contra
las urnas electrónicas y las principales
instituciones del país hay que destacar
que había preocupación con esta
ceremonia que incluso se iba a celebrar
el 19 de diciembre y ha sido adelantada
una semana porque desde el inicio de
noviembre los bolsonaristas siguen
acampados delante de los cuarteles
militares en las principales ciudades de
Brasil algunos los más radicales
amenazaban con
este acto finalmente las protestas en
Brasilia han sido mucho menores de lo
que se esperaba y la pregunta ahora es
si seguirán acampados los bolsonaristas
y se intentarán boicotear la investidura
el 1 de enero nosotros estaremos allí en
Brasilia para contarlo y pasamos a
Ucrania uno de los frentes más
importantes en un campo de batalla es el
médico en la región de dones el trabajo
de uno de los hospitales de campaña
cerca del frente de combate cumple una
labor fundamental a la hora de salvar
las vidas de los soldados heridos en
medio de la invasión rusa
otro frente en el campo de batalla
ucraniano en medio de los intensos
combates contra las fuerzas invasoras
rusas los médicos apostados cerca de las
zonas de acción cumplen jornadas de ardo
trabajo pero no todas son iguales Hay
días que llegan muchos heridos graves
cuatro o cinco amputaciones a la vez
otros días no llega nadie durante dos
tres o cuatro horas ningún día es igual
a otro claro Hay días difíciles sobre
todo cuando los nuestros son atacados
también pasan por ellos pacientes
especiales quienes envían mensajes de
cariño y agradecimiento
unicef contabilizó en septiembre unos
mil veintidós niños afectados entre
muertos y heridos
tenemos que asegurarnos que los niños no
mueran y lleguen al siguiente punto de
evacuación
Para ser honesta es muy difícil cuando
traen niños muy pequeños transportamos
niños sin piernas mentalmente es muy
duro cuando está sola puedes llorar pero
cruzas las puertas y tienes que sonreír
porque ellos te miran y te dicen ya
estoy mejor
los galenos son testigos de muestras de
compañerismo solo vistas en escenas de
cine
muy a menudo llegan y dicen cóseme y
vuelvo con los muchachos
los muchachos están allí ni siquiera uno
ha dicho Llévame quiero ir a casa
la guerra que el 24 de diciembre
cumplirá 10 meses de acción
ininterrumpida ha dejado hasta el
momento cifras significativas entre
ambos bandos por primera vez desde
finales de agosto el asesor presidencial
ucraniano mijailo podoliacán informó que
hasta principios de diciembre se
registraron entre 10.000 y 13.000 bajas
fatales Mientras que el alto mando
militar estadounidense aseguró que tanto
Rusia como Ucrania han sufrido más de
100.000 bajas entre decesos y afectados
hasta que este informativo Gracias por
acompañarnos
[Música]